if you're looking for ways to make more
and better connections than this video
is for you
what's up elimination it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have amazing talent inside
you that I want to see explode out onto
the world and one of the things that I
get asked a lot is how do I make
connections I know that I can't do this
business on my own I need a team of
people
I need references I need customers I
need people talking about me how do I
make those connections and so today I'm
gonna share with you my seven ways and
how entrepreneurs can make connections
[Music]
way number one is the pick offline or
online I think it really leans in
heavily on what you're good at
I much prefer the online versus the
offline I'm not a fan of going up to
people and shaking their hands and
talking to people at the airport and the
people next to me and striking up a
conversation with the person you
elevator next to me so it's
understanding what you're really good at
what your personality lends you to and
working with that instead of fighting
against it instead of making you a
fantastic network or salesperson if
that's not who you are or instead of
fighting to make you a fantastic online
marketer if you have no interest in that
then it's much better to stand on the
legs that you have and go far and run
fast than to try to get some new legs
and do something that you have no
interest in and so I'm going to share
with you in my other six points three
strategies for offline three strategies
with online and I would highly recommend
you audit yourself at the beginning to
figure out which one you want to lean in
on more because that's who you are
because that's what you have ultimate
success
[Music]
so let's start off with the offline
connections way number two is going to
be a 10 industry events and by industry
events I mean the industry that you're
in as well as the industry that your
customers are in so as an example if you
are a website designer and you're trying
to get more website design business
why no would be attending website design
industry conferences to meet not
competitors as much as meet partners
meet people that I might be able to form
alliances with make some kind of
connection with that could help me scale
my business but also looking at who are
my core customers and where are they
hanging out so as an example if I'm
trying to target florists if I am the
website designer for florists that's
where I really want to go all in on then
I'd be looking at any floral conventions
that are happening inside my city
outside the city potentially to travel
to because you want to be spending as
much time around your customers as well
as potential partners as possible way
number three speak at events this is
something that I much prefer to do as an
introvert I don't like going up and
introducing myself and striking up
conversations so I get invited to speak
at events because I'm known as an expert
in my industry I speak at events and
then after I speak people come up to me
and they ask me questions and they want
to find a way to work with me and so
whatever event is coming up in your
industry again if you are web designer
you could speak if you have talent you
got skills but every time they do an
event they put out a call for speakers
you could be a speaker at that event or
again in the flower in the street that's
who your customers are you could put on
a seminar there about how to build a
great website for florists so any time
there's this convention coming up I
would look at not just going as an
exhibitor not just going as somebody to
network with people and shake hands and
just someone who pays to get in but
trying to be on there as an expert as a
speaker as a presenter because it's a
great way to be a magnet and attract
people to you
[Music]
we're number four is attract attention
as an introvert what I love doing in
networking situation since I'm not going
to go up and talk to people is I try to
attract attention to myself so that
people want to talk to me so an easy way
to do it is by being a speaker and
you're on stage and afterwards people
come and talk to you before nobody may
know who you are but after they want to
take pictures with you or ask you
questions or exchange emails and get to
know you the other way I'd do it is if
I'm not speaking at an event I just go I
wear my branded stuff I wear a t-shirt
or my hoodie that has my name on it and
I go to the busiest room and I sit right
in the middle and I start doing social
media stuff I start replying the people
on social media I think the worst thing
you can do is know that you need to talk
to people and then just sit in the
corner the corner where there's nobody
and you never get any attention and
nobody comes and talks to you and you
spend your whole day doing that you're
not gonna get the connections that
you're striving for so I go to the
middle I have my branded stuff and I
start working because when I'm working
when I'm answering people on social
media it's just Instagram videos Twitter
video snapchat videos responding to
people when I'm doing that I'm also
projecting energy I'm also in a much
more positive state than if I'm like
this trying to do email them just to
myself this makes it look like I don't
want to be disturbed where if I'm doing
things like this and I have abundance of
energy then on the breaks people want to
come and talk to me and so some people
I'm fortunate and some people recognize
the brand now they know who I am they
recognize the face or subscribers that
have seen the videos and they strike up
a conversation but if you don't have a
brand yet then I'd find some way to make
myself stand out that still relates to
my brain somehow so maybe you're wearing
a crazy hat or a different hoodie or
sweater or different paints or shoes
something that allows you to express who
you are but doesn't just fit into the
norm of what everybody else is doing
there and so if I had these furry
slippers that tied into my website
design brain somehow I would wear those
furry slippers out be in the middle of a
big room and I would be doing with
confidence my instagrams my snap chats
my Twitter my responses and if you don't
have fans yet you don't have a following
yet it doesn't matter look at trending
topics on Twitter and then just start
responding look at trending photos on
Instagram and click the three dots and
just
make videos for those people who created
that content you don't have to respond
to your fans yet but you're projecting
value out and then I see you as this
confident person who has this little
crazy thing going on and I want to come
and introduce myself so that you're
again a magnet for people so those are
three for offline let's now get to the
three for online strategies to make
connections way number 5 is to use
influencers influencers can be a great
way to make connections if you know them
then they can pass your name on to a
whole bunch of other people so for me I
started with Tim Schmoyer and Derral
Eve's when I was starting my YouTube
channel and I looked up to them and they
were the experts and I loved everything
they were creating I was and this is key
guys I was an important part of their
community first I didn't just spam Tim
or Derral and say hey can we do
something together
you're an influencer I love to work with
you right don't do that that's the worst
thing ever be a part of their community
be somebody who they would recognize
when you wrote to them so I watched all
of his videos I watched all of their OHS
videos and new ones and the old ones and
I started leaving comments I was really
active in the comments on their videos
pretty much every new video they put out
I would leave comments and maybe
multiple comments maybe get involved in
the discussion and try to add value to
the other people who are leaving
comments and the more you do that the
more they're gonna recognize you and
that's the point you want to be a known
quantity and then when I reached out to
do a collaboration I can make a video on
their channel did multiple
collaborations with them they know me
they recognize my face they're willing
to take that email they're willing to
have a conversation I still need to
bring them value somehow right they're
not just going to put me up on their
channel but they're willing to have the
conversation because they recognize my
face and they appreciate all the value
that I've brought in them so there's a
lot of people on this channel who leave
occasional comments and honestly because
of the size I won't know who all of you
are but there are some superfans who are
on every video who are on every live
chat who are always asking great
questions
we're always sharing my stuff we're
always thanking me and always part of
the community who have made moderators
and administrators if any of those
people asked me for something whether
it's can you review my book can you
check out my website can you give me
feedback on something can we do a
collaboration it's not a guarantee that
put them up on my channel but I'm gonna
do my best to help them out because of
all the value that they brought me and
so that's the key look at the
influencers that you need to connect
with who will help spread your message
for you who can give you key
introductions provide as much value to
them first as possible so that you think
you will be a known quantity when you
reach out and then we chat with your ask
whatever it is that you're looking for
to get their help with then you reach
out it's not a guaranteed yes but that's
how you build a strategy way number six
is talk about trending topics on almost
every social media platform they show
you what the trending topics are and it
allows you to be able to join the
conversation inject your own personality
your opinions your suggestions your
advice your feelings on what people are
talking about so Twitter as an example
if you go to the Twitter homepage it
always shows you what the trending
topics are for that country you could
then create content around each of them
now I may not relate to what you're
interested in they may not relate to
your business somehow and that's fine
you may not have an opinion don't force
it if you don't have it but if you have
something to say join in the trending
conversation will allow people to find
you and learn about you and they say hi
I agree with that person I wonder what
else they do and then they follow you on
Twitter and then they subscribe to you
on YouTube and then they look at your
website and they set up your email list
and maybe they buy your product the
other way to do it is to look at
trending videos that are happening on
YouTube as an example and maybe you
don't have the ability to create a
training video for yourself but you
could go to those videos and get
involved in the discussion again see
what's happening what's trending in your
industry and in general and if you have
a perspective then you can create
content or join in the discussion around
that topic so other people who are also
talking about it will notice you and
some people will disagree with you when
you hate your point of view and that's
great you don't want those people in
your life they won't follow you they
won't go to your website they won't care
about you and others will look at that
and they may not be even writing they
may just be following the conversation
they'll look at what you're saying and
say huh I like what that person has to
say and they'll be more curious about
you and then they'll reach out so again
we're using online to be a magnet to us
to bring the right people to us
[Music]
and finally we number seven is creating
powerful content so now we're not just
creating the tweet or just responding to
other people's messages we're actually
out there creating powerful content
ourselves one of the best ways that I
make connections is this is my youtube
channel we've got a million plus
followers all of my speaking gigs all of
my brand deals all of the outreach that
I get for the most part is through
YouTube and if it comes from Instagram
or Twitter it's usually because they
were first a subscriber to me on youtube
and then they decided to send me a DM on
Twitter or Instagram and so by making
content and now you'll have to look at
me as the example you don't have to be
making three videos a day you don't have
to have a million subscribers but making
content that you're proud of picking a
platform that fits for you and then
making content that you're proud of on a
consistent basis to expose your message
to show yourself as an expert as a
thought leader in what you're doing and
people who resonate with it will want to
do some kind of business with you will
want to form connections with you people
who reach out to me are the ones who
love the believe message they love
helping entrepreneurs they want to be a
part of the mission that I'm on in part
because I try to be positive and
optimistic and share believe in every
video that I make if you don't like
believe and don't like helping
entrepreneurs chances are you're not
watching very many of these videos right
chances are you tuned out already you
saw my face and clicked off and banned
me from coming up in your stream again
right that's probably what would happen
and that's fine because those people I
won't work really well with but the ones
who love the message and love helping
entrepreneurs and want to have a big
impact and love the mission they're
gonna be the ones who reach out to me so
again it's about being a magnet using
awesome content that drive people in
they self select they do all the work of
selecting in instead of me reaching out
to try to see if somebody's interested
and then it forms a lot of connections
and the cycle repeats itself instead of
me following up with people which I
never do I hate following up with people
instead of following up I use that time
to then create more content to be an
even stronger magnet to bring more
people the right people to me so that's
my advice on the seven ways to make
connections I would love to know from
you which one was your favorite which
one are you going to try to apply
somehow in your life or business did I
miss an 8 9 10 that you want to add to
the list leave it down in the comments
I'm really looking forward to hearing
what you have to say now I made this
video because you coke you toku asked me
to if there's a topic you'd like me to
cover in a future video check out the
request line in the description you can
go and cast your vote finally I want to
give a quick chatter - Cloris Kiley
Cloris thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my new book the top ten truths
of success posting it online on your
Twitter taking that awesome picture I
love seeing the smile I really
appreciate all your support and I hope
you enjoy the book so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon if you had to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you up or that would be like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details